how's it going guys uh greg and john
here today
and we are going to talk about uh this i
think this is the third week my god i've
lost count it's been going on for so
long
of the johnny depp amber heard trial
amber heard had a couple days of
testimony
and
here's my thought process on this was
we originally
i just wanted to do like a podcast
because have like a real discussion
it's like the back and forth that john
and i have when talking about this
because i've listened if if i haven't
listened to all i've at least listened
to the vast majority of this trial and
uh definitely all of amber hurt's
testimony as the most recent part of it
and
uh we have a podcast that i was like we
could just upload it to that
and so if there's then we have a video
recording going on right now so
if there's no video there's no video
there's a video
it's up we i decided okay you know what
fine screw it let's just throw it up
there
uh because
yeah and they go i know
like here's here's the truth i i i i
personally and i consume this trial way
more than john does i i personally could
do a video about this every day like if
i really wanted to milk the most popular
subject right now in entertainment media
uh yeah i easily could because i i i'm
so up to date with it and it's something
i talk about people
all the time and this would be like the
third thing
second thing was not even like a real
i was just like that dub of uh jason
momoa yeah the second real discussion
about it you did that one editorial
piece yeah and this
the thing is though is like i i i'll
hear other videos and such and
um it seems like you kind of have to be
one-sided especially if you're doing
youtube videos it's pretty much you got
to be like a hundred percent all in
johnny depp you know that's how all
debates work and no no no gray area
whatsoever i i know right now even
saying that that just that turns people
off right away
and
i do have my opinions about a a lot more
than
than just justice for johnny or
something like that and so i'm just
hoping that this can be more of a an
open discussion and
really just talking the way how
we talk
when
there isn't a camera rolling and we're
not worried about presentation or watch
time comments yeah
yeah like really just like try to be
honest which is kind of the challenge of
theirs on a much bigger global scale of
be honest in front of a room full of
people
and
and and then knowing this is being
broadcasted to the world and everyone's
having everyone's playing jury right now
so
yeah
following up on everything where to kick
it off i guess i'm
there's a bit like questions like is is
amber heard telling the truth or not is
she telling the truth
and
i don't know it's probably more
complicated than yes or no
right this whole thing seems more
complicated than a simple yes or no yeah
it's like there's a lot of evidence to
go against her
that they've managed to get physical
evidence of like
audio recordings and
just testimonials of people countless
messages
yeah yeah some real emotional
testimonials too
to go against her and i'll i'll say this
i do have a hard time believing her i do
i have a very difficult time believing
her when i watch her testify
i have a lot of the same
thoughts that i think a lot of other
people do
and i i weirdly don't go
on twitter
or
scroll through the comments because i
try to
first figure out how i'm feeling
before i
let myself be influenced by another
thought and then sometimes then
afterwards i'll probably i'll go on and
i'll see how people are
thinking and i'm like yeah that is that
is sort of where my head's at too and it
is something i try to figure out you
know it's like one of the first things
is i i don't really
watch the trial i mainly listen
but when i would listen to amber heard
and especially during a lot of like the
the deep size
and the
the this like
this
i the way i describe it is it feels very
theatrical
like it's it sounds like uh it's almost
a narration something about it would
ring false to me that i would i found
myself watching her
instead of
simply listening to her and like a lot
of people like one of the most joked
about things is something that i
definitely was thinking was
the crying that she does
seems
fake
because
when someone cries there's more than
just
tears
hey she doesn't have any tears
so that's like sign number one to me
that this this seems fake
um
the other part is like there's other
signs of you know your cheeks can turn
red there can be snot
there there's there's cracking in the
voice like real cracking that happens
your eyes turn red you know there's a
there's a lot of that that doesn't
really seem like
like real tears and i'm not gonna be the
kind of person who would say
a person who has suffered domestic
violence
wouldn't
recount a story like that because
everyone deals with dv differently
everyone handles it differently and
everyone is at a different stage
in their life when it comes to dv a lot
of people haven't gotten over it a lot
of people
have been able to put it behind them and
a lot of people have gone to therapy a
lot happened so everyone has like a
different way of
recounting it i would love to
go into
my life
i choose not to
um only because
i'm aware of
the connection it has to
other people that are still in my life
and i wouldn't want to then
inadvertently put parts of their life
out there does that does that make sense
yeah no i don't want to
it it by you know by association it it
it involves them yeah it's not only your
story yeah yeah and so that's that's a
big part of why i choose no that's a
choice i made like
um before even
we were doing youtube
like that was something i learned from
facebook of putting stuff out there and
i decided just you know i'm just not
gonna do that and um
so i do take the subject really serious
you know some some criticisms about
amber heard i i do
i don't fully agree with
of like the this person wouldn't do that
i'm like well you know i've i i have
been around people like when you i've
had to tell my story to people
and i will
talk to
you know if i don't really know the
person i can look them in the eyes i can
talk to them i mean it's a little
something you told me that is so true
though is like
99 of us don't know what it's like
and again you know that's what i mean
it's so it's it's so easy for
if you are someone who has suffered from
it especially a woman
to
put your experience
onto
how she's describing it
and then go i don't i didn't do i
wouldn't do that and i and i know other
people who wouldn't do that so i
i'm i believe she's false
same time there's the flip side
yeah everybody behaves differently yeah
same time there's the flip side though
where people would
people who have suffered
the stories that she is recounting
might automatically believe her
simply because of the fact that it it's
there's this
identification this catharsis
this
feeling of bravery of
because i do believe full-heartedly that
there are so many women
like countless women
who have been
who have suffered domestic violence who
have suffered sexual assault who then
don't get a day in court don't get don't
get a voice or immediately shut down
anything there's no retribution there's
nothing and it's just damage that they
then have to
move forward with
and
that falls on then it becomes only their
responsibility
to deal with that and that's a lonely
harsh struggle i see yeah and friends of
mine even to today who have been through
some things that have never received any
kind of
retribution and and less too just broad
support and it's it's really hard to
watch
and it can be very high it can be very
isolating for people
so yeah that's what i mean like both
sides seem possible like
one way to look at it is this is why i
think she's lying and another way to
look at it is like this is why she's
telling the truth because why why would
she do this well yeah yeah and i mean
you know there are all sorts of
conspiracy theories you can have and i i
do believe that yeah there's some people
out there who are sociopathic and who do
connive but i
have trouble figuring out if that's
really what's happening here because
yeah i look at the situation i go okay
even if she was in this to get some big
divorce settlement or something or to
take advantage of a cultural wave it
seems like you're talking about like the
beginning like when when she first went
got the restraining order or it got
publicized and then the op-ed piece
the beginning and the perpetuation
too
even because now this has become such a
spiral of
time pain and money and she's
counter-suit like johnny depp is
counter-suing her currently and then
she's going to counter sue him again and
that suggests to me that at least either
these two parties really believe in
their stories
or she if she is a sociopath has just
dug the hole so deep that she can't
climb out now and i find that
like the last resort of thinking i guess
is the sort of cartoon villainy of like
i'm going to be a sociopath wreck your
career get your money and skate away as
some kind of social justice icon it it
seems
like this is a bad way to achieve that
to me
i mean yeah
because i mean
at this point i look at the situation
i'm like what is anyone gaining from
this and i mean johnny depp certainly
seems to be gaining in the public eye
but even the things that they have put
into evidence
don't really shine a flattering light on
either of them and they contribute to me
more of that gray area i mean as it
appears especially after in light of
that one particular tape they often
replay of her going like okay i didn't
slap you this way i hit you and you know
defining the ways in which you know uh
you can be hit and and what his response
should or shouldn't be and belittling it
like there are certain aspects of her
you know behavior on record that do seem
abusive and do seem like they could be
outside
just the genuine sort of i don't know
what to do in this situation
um but at the same time you know there's
a whole bunch of gray area especially
involving drugs that i think just makes
this whole situation really hard for me
to get a clear read on because while i'm
like yeah i don't think johnny depp is
necessarily the monster as they keep
coming back to that motif of the monster
i believe the monster is based on
something real though and is probably in
there to some degree and i mean you look
at the way he talks about her
and i'm like yeah i mean there's some
malice there so it's one of those things
where i don't think this is just a false
situation that she is contributed
just to get money
i guess is is is the one conclusion i
can solidly maybe get close to
that's
it
well that's the thing is like there's
more to come there's there's more to
come too and like i said we're all
playing jury that's where this all keeps
coming back to i mean you guys talking
about like let's let's talk about the
the johnny depp side of things because
the flip side too also is why would
johnny depp go through all this
if
he really did do this you know because a
lot of the time
like maybe he just had enough evidence
to kind of put her to shame
whatever like if i'm playing devil's
advocate on on certain things because i
i like it's hollywood and there's so
many
entertainment in music and movies and
granted it's a different time because
the metoo movement and such people
taking more serious
at the same time a lot of people get
away with [ __ ] all the time you know
and i really do
think like yeah this would have followed
him
this this would have followed him but he
was already on a
rebound in a lot of ways if he just
stuck true to his career you know like
it seems like he really
cared
at least that's the way it it perceived
to me because
he was still doing movies he did get
grindelwald you know like he did have
films coming he got like pirates five
still came out and didn't make a billion
dollars but it still made a lot of money
and it's
like there was enough
this is the most his truth has been out
there this is the like all these things
that are being
headlined and clipped out and
actually making the news that's been out
there for years and and it's only now
because of the trial that it's in the
mainstream media
so
that helps them out because i think at
least in the court of public opinion
he's definitely won
so many more people over
what were you talking about or there was
something you said you said a lot of
thoughts and so there's trying to turn
to that thing where i was making a lot
of mental notes and i was like oh no
lost lost most of them yeah
johnny depp in the court of public
opinion generally no no no there's
something else about her
i'm not sure like i
i was literally sitting watching the
testimony of her and going
why
why don't i really
believe her and i think there's another
there are things i'm questionable about
for sure
like especially with something that is
not in the trial
but is
uh was making its way on social media
but i guess it might count as hearsay or
some [ __ ]
objection
is um
her you see you're talking about like
johnny depp's stories and they're both
painting each other not in the greatest
light like yeah johnny depp when he
testifies
he
has stories that go in there that don't
paint him in the greatest light
but then when i hear the someone say but
however however when i hear
the like the audio recordings and such
it still sounds like this is the same
guy who's testifying do you know what i
mean yeah even even at the the even when
you get him like saying something
horrible
it still sounds like no this lines up
with the same guy doesn't seem like he's
painting a false
image
he doesn't feel like he's orchestrating
yeah yeah the the skeptic in me will go
join up is an amazing actor
that's where the skeptic of me comes out
right yeah maybe he just really knows
what he's doing and uh based my
testimony on keith richards
no it seems it seems really consistent
and he has a big reputation of for being
a certain type of individual to others
so it lines up still even with the stuff
that doesn't paint him as well in a good
life that came out during when it was
really his time with his witnesses and
such
whereas with amber heard
um
it she really paints herself as
like super duper innocent like so
innocent
not the aggressor she's she's like such
a victim
and he was this
monstrosity
like it like it's just it's such the
antithesis it's such a wild antithesis
to there's like no gray area with her
you know yeah and her and the story
she's telling that i'm like this doesn't
at all like this just seems to
contradict so much of the uh the
testimonials we've heard
the audios we've heard all these things
and the other part of me does go to
like with with the
we will talk about some other stuff but
the
when it comes to the
the acts of violence of like these just
sheer like it's insane what she is
describing just insane what she
this this terrific it's horrific and
there are people who really suffer that
and worse and sometimes leads to death
these are real things that she is
describing like terrible terrible things
and
and and apar like if she's telling the
truth and
good on her you know she's telling the
truth and good
the part of me that makes me doubtful
is
when when i'm like how come there's like
she she clearly would take videos and
photos of him like she passed out he's
got a little bit of a temper tantrum
right now uh we're again we're in an
argument let me record this as a way to
have something on him to expose him in
case
and and it made me go well why
why don't you have like
any photos of this sometimes when she's
describing incidents like a big part of
this whole ordeal is
you know the the photos that did become
famous where she when she got the
restraining order and she was all
bruised and then she like went on a talk
show i think it was cordon like the next
day
and after that the day of that supposed
beating and then she she was fine like
like no one saw anything on her like a
lot went to go that was fake what she
did that was there's so much to support
that that was fake so when she's
describing
this
this guy
you know
it's
it it makes me questionable of how come
there's not like when we're talking
about domestic violence or sexual
assault it's it's so hard
the reason why it's so hard for women
especially
in is because it's it's so hard to like
get the perfect crime that is documented
and videotaped and recorded in order to
prove your point you know it's it's
really it's so
it's so hard so that's the thing that
she can lean on
that's why i'm bringing up all these
other things that she documented
so how come
and and the thing is so much of this so
volatile and emotional that i'm talking
about
kind of a logical way of thinking
when a lot of the time in toxic
relationships
logic is thrown out of the window like
logically they should have broken up a
long time ago toxicity is there to mask
the logic yeah yeah
and you know you hear about the the way
they started their relationship like
they the both of their testimonies line
up
of they were both coming off of the
heels like johnny depp was still with
his girlfriend and according to his
testimony and
you know she
would think was in the middle of a
divorce
or separation something of that nature
so they're both coming off the heels and
ideally when you're in a relationship
that's ending you want to be single for
a while so you can heal and grieve from
that from such a commitment of that life
partner that you had
and and then go into relationships so
when you have that toxic whatever
whatever negativity has brewed up in you
with that relationship ideally you want
to get over that first
so you don't bring it into your next
relationship yeah you know
and it sounds like this was destined
from the get-go to be something that was
oftentimes we people mistake toxicity
for passion
and
some people think you need those fights
yeah
to to keep you guys in a gravitational
pull or something like that and yeah you
have a situation that began out of
i'm going to assume some level of trauma
you know two relationships dissolving a
new one coming out of that dissolution
but also between two people with as this
trial is well established
a lot of history of abuse in childhood
in their younger lives and i definitely
believe that those things can harmonize
later on and can bring something you
know out
of
people and yeah i mean to go back to
what to what you said like that's the
main like
i guess i sympathize in a way i hesitate
to to pick one team because the quote
always comes back to me that there are
three sides to any story there's mine
yours and the truth
and i feel like the truth always has to
be somewhere in between and yeah the big
thing about amber heard to me is that
there are aspects
of what she's willing to give up that
don't seem to ring as true as what
johnny's willing to give up it seems
like his testimony he was pretty much
they constantly asked him if they're
reading his words correctly half those
words are pretty
uh you know unpleasant and he's always
just like yeah yeah you did
so there is a certain willingness i
think to accept some of that behavior
but
the problem is the digger i the deeper i
dig the more i'm like well that could be
a tactic you know you admit to some
smaller things so that you can deny the
bigger thing or you know there's so many
gray areas to play at and to look at and
yeah i i think ultimately
the problem for me in just going johnny
that must be right is the fact that for
a lot of these situations he is
allegedly on many a substance and i just
believe that
things happen when you're unaware of
yourself
so i can't fully
discredit the idea that amber heard
could be telling the truth and i know
that it's really hard for people
in her position which is what worries me
the most because if she is truly being
fraudulent in these claims and as being
the sociopath the court of public
opinion has has deemed her that's bad
like that's bad for the future that's
bad for
like that could set a precedent
that could set the whole movement and i
know the metoo movement is very
contentious for people and a lot of
people
don't really like it
uh and i feel like something like this
could easily set the progress made by
something like that back really heavily
or call further into doubt like i get
what people struggle with in the
argument of like we believe all women
immediately but at the same time to me
it's sort of like there better be some
really extreme circumstances as to how
these falsehoods were
contrived
basically because again it just seems to
my moral compass it's about the the most
vile thing you can do to fabricate
something like this and then to draw it
out into this kind of circus so a party
even like amber heard's ex-assistant
came out
talking about how uh amber heard this is
before the trial stole her sexual
assault story
i mean if that's true that's disgusting
that's absolutely disgusting because the
problem is that it's really hard for a
lot of women out there i don't speak
from experience but i have seen the
experiences of just friends alone
no that's what's so angering that's
that's what's angry about it if it is
indeed if she is not telling the truth
it's just
that's the part of
i think the thing is is that
the thing like you do got to take a side
that i'm not saying you have to i'm
saying like that's that's how the the
public on like social media makes you
one feel yeah like you have to take a
side
you know because in this court case like
with johnny depp
even if it was reactionary abuse right
even if it was reactionary if he did
indeed like
fight back in any way or hit back
it's
that data was gonna that could take him
down
in this specific legal case
a lot of people will defend him
that in this legal case that's bad news
for johnny depp i could that could
really result in him losing
so
the
the part of it that i think johnny depp
owns up to is like being
at times emotionally abused i don't know
if he's actually declared it but it's
he's you know talked about being like
emotionally and verbally abusive they're
even if it is reaction even if it is
reactionary abuse it still is in that
category yeah it's demonstrably evident
by the the videos and the tapes that
they show like yeah there's definitely
toxicity and abuse in these rooms with
these two sides yeah where
where i'm not i'm not trying to see like
to give
there's this one part that really casts
a lot of doubt when it came to for me in
terms of the johnny depp side
uh there was this like text message that
uh let me see if i could find it really
quick i'll just
i'll just read it
because um
i think it is important and i don't
think it might be brought up in the
trial
um i i haven't seen it brought up in the
trial yet
but i i do think it's an important thing
to bring up where
she was talking with
here it is i've found it it's been going
around online
uh johnny depp's ex-assistant stephen uh
deuters to amber hurt
where amber told the story on on in the
testimony recently about getting kicked
by johnny depp when he was drugged up
and
stephen said i think he's just texted
you he's incredibly apologetic and know
that he has done wrong he wants to get
better now he's been very explicit about
that this morning feels like we're at a
critical juncture she says yes but i
don't know how to be around him after
what he did to me yesterday i don't know
if i can stay with him these are private
text messages
he wants and steven says he wants to see
you so much he's distraught
amber says don't worry about the flights
i'll be taking care of them myself thank
you look
he thinks he doesn't deserve this
obviously he has no idea what he did or
to the extent that he did it if someone
was truly honest with him about how bad
it really was he'd be appalled the man
and definitely wouldn't say to me that
he doesn't deserve it i'm sad he doesn't
have a better way to really know the
severity of his actions yesterday
unfortunately for me i remember in full
detail everything that happened
and this is the kicker
no pun intended bad terrible choice of
words
terrible choices unintentionally
um
he was this is steven says he was
appalled when i told him he kicked you
he cried it was disgusting and he knows
it
i wasn't with him this is where it's cut
off though oh like i wasn't with him
when he and then it's cut off so i don't
know what the rest of that sentence is
when he apologized and made everything
right again or i wasn't with him when
when he did it or something you know
um
but this is like way before any of this
other stuff was like really coming out
this is like still when they were like
no let's make this relationship work
yeah yeah
well yeah i mean and to think too i mean
there's the evidence of this case alone
but i remember you way back like sort of
absorbing and being sent
even more
you know stuff in the past
yeah and yeah i mean it's a moment like
that like that's a pretty interesting
thing to me and that's
again the the the major gray area for me
with johnny depp is like generally just
the way it strikes me the way people's
accounts go yeah it seems like he is a
sweet genuine probably very caring guy
when he's aware i know people that know
him and
and
i also
am very cautious of my bias that i could
have
simply because
i love the actor johnny depp i loved it
yeah and i oh even when i thought even
before all this happened and i thought
his his career was going weird in town
i was always rudin and it would always
watch the trailer if he was in it you
know i was always curiou i'm always
curious to see what he's doing like i'm
always fascinated by him he's the star
of my very favorite movie yeah several
of my other favorite movies yeah
he's he is
a talent that i've always admired and
i've loved watching interviews with him
you know and i've wanted to be like
you know yeah yeah he's that kind of
dude that you would see you're just like
he just seems so cool
guys like him women like him
and
he doesn't seem like an ego maniacal
dude he just seems like he really
doesn't give a [ __ ] and he's like cool
and calm you know yeah absolutely and
and
and
has these fun idiosyncrasies that i just
admire you know and i
there's this story and not to make
things
much much worse
but every great story starts that way
that it's not being brought up because i
believe here's what i'll say i
full-heartedly believe johnny depp is
telling his version of the truth that's
how it appears even in these text
messages
right that i just read yeah he's
there's nothing of the the account is
he doesn't if he did it he certainly
doesn't remember it and when being told
he did it he broke down crying mm-hmm
you know
it feels like it tracks it feels more
like if he did do something he wasn't
full he wasn't um he did it uh [ __ ]
and
how was the [ __ ] word he was
inebriated yeah he was a nebri yeah yeah
he wasn't in control or aware of his
full faculties yeah like if he if he did
do it but um that's how it strikes i
mean that would be absolutely diabolical
if it were to come out that you know
this is all an act on his side yeah i
mean from from him i mean it's still
abuse but
it certainly seems as though the the
danger with johnny depp is more
is he hopped up is he coping you know
talks with toxic substances and whatnot
and is that leading to these
retaliations and these uh uh outbursts
these these lashings out so to speak
yeah like
i remember years ago there was this he
told the story on inside the actor's
studio with james lipton i'm not finding
it there's like a two-minute it's like a
two-minute thing that he was talking
about about being bullied specifically
being bullied and his mother who
obviously played a big influence into
his development like anyone anyone who's
around their mom growing up if they
would but in terms of his trauma
of you know explanation as to why he
would be attracted to such a
relationship
uh his mother played a big part and he
used to paint he wouldn't talk about
this side of his mother until this trial
and all this [ __ ]
versus uh on inside the actor's studio
he was telling a story about being
bullied and if i remember correctly
you could probably find it and you could
correct me if i get any of this wrong
if i remember correctly
the story he was telling was that
if they start bullying you
take the rock
and
either threaten them or hit them with it
and then he said after he did one of
those i'm not going to say which one he
did because i simply don't remember if
he just threatened with it or actually
hit them i don't remember
um
but he said he did that and they never
bothered him again so he's learned to
like
that's how he deals with bullies granted
this interview was years ago he's in his
50s about time he married amber people
people grow and like i feel like i'm a
different person every two to three
years i might look back on this
conversation in two to three years maybe
even
a week from nowhere
and then depending on how this all goes
and and and be like oh man you know i
actually think very differently than i
did then
not just about the subject just about
life in general
and so you know to take something
someone said like 20 years ago and apply
it you know that's why i think a lot of
it's like silly to to bring up you know
like in 1998 you did this you know
yeah like he's probably a completely
different person
yeah it's like you can draw something
from that but also i feel like the
passage of time needs the credit that
it's due at the same time this this uh
sentiment
that like he didn't abuse these other
people
so why would he do this now and i'm like
fair
true if he didn't
that he didn't harm them
um
same time there's a different
relationship that was then yeah this is
a different relationship coming off of
one that was ending badly and clearly
with someone who i do for i do believe
was the
main
main one to provoke the main aggressor
the main initiator amber who they they
have audio of them directly of if of him
saying like you start physical fights
you start these fights and she's like
yeah i start these fights because you're
you won't engage with me unless i hate
you you know like so that's just like
it's pretty much an admission of guilt
on theirs that she is the aggressor
she's the star so
you know that that's why i think a lot
of
people believe that
many that where johnny depp comes from
is reactionary abuse that's why i keep
saying that word
because he's not
he would he wouldn't just instigate this
or start this you know and she seems
easily provoked
yeah and she's got abandonment issues
man like i get it i i get i understand
the like it's it's i'm saying is i
understand
not that i
i don't sympathize with the choice and
actions i don't want that to be
misconstrued i do understand abandonment
issues very well though
and
to um have a histrionic personality
disorder i'm not that well versed in it
but see there's the other i don't like
zip zagging around here but that's the
other part was that the dr curry person
who who testified
talked about how she i think she was
saying she believed amber heard has
histrionic personality disorder
and a lot of the symptoms
of why she
said that
is shown
during
her testimony
like
a lot of the things that she described
are are are there and i wasn't even
thinking about that on the surface
it would some someone did i saw on this
was a thing i did see on social media of
someone clipped out the part where she
because i listened to a testimony and i
kind of forgot about all that
because there's i'm just absorbing this
whole thing
and then i and then and i listened to it
again and then i continued watching the
amber her testimony i'm like yeah this
is all
there
so
i forgot my the original thing i was
talking about before the historic
personality disorder well in abandonment
issues and abandonment like a lot of
things that like fallen off onto this
category that
the actions of that that are described
of this individual that are caught on on
recordings and such
do seem that way of
someone who does suffer from from this
damage and then when i watch like a
testimony and it doesn't ring
sincere
but you were saying something that i'm
like that's all that that could
potentially be a fair point of
she must be aware
that
the the public is not in her favor so
she might be working extra hard to sell
the story yeah and the burden of this
particular trial is basically on her to
prove that her account is correct beyond
a shadow of a doubt and so like she
might be telling the truth but she might
be playing up the emotions and being
more animated yeah i mean i don't know
you know and like i really need to cry
yeah like i don't know how law show to
take this but yeah i mean it's got to be
really strange and uncomfortable for any
person to do what is essentially a big
open public therapy session yeah uh
where you you know you tear open all the
wounds and i mean i know they're that
we're where this ver where it depends on
a few people strangers
determining whether or not
you are telling you are sincere yeah or
whether you're being truthful yeah and
whether
the abuse that at least you have
experienced yourself or that you you
know
feel is part of your reason for being
here you know is either legitimized or
delegitimized based on you know those
decisions and what those people have to
say and so as much as there are body
language experts out there i've seen
just as many videos in my life about
body language experts just nailing
people and then the flip side where
people go
yes but there are like so many things
that influence
you could have kept talking oh sorry
yeah i just didn't want you to miss a
minute um
but yeah like there's so many factors
that contribute to body language and
yeah like they certainly could be
indicative of her being disingenuous on
the stand but i feel like especially
she to me she is the loneliest person in
that room no matter what because she has
to defend this really horrific account
which if it's true
has to be emotionally
difficult to say the least and if it's
not true it's got to be
just as difficult in a totally other way
that requires way more mental spiritual
awful coordination well i mean you have
they have these videos of like
what it's like when johnny depp shows up
to court and fans are like yippee johnny
i love you justice and then
amber shows up and it's not welcoming
you know roll out the carpet for her you
know yeah it's not like there's a team
amber that's just as vocal and then
people who want to like attend the trial
a lot of them in the background who are
sitting there
i i i don't know but they kind of read
like some of them are johnny depp fans
well and they've had to
to calm them down
or else kick them out yeah yeah yeah the
judges had to say that
well i think does a pretty good job that
the judge is trying to keep this even
and moving along as best as she can yeah
well yeah it's because like i you know
if i
even though i have a really hard time
like
buying the sincerity of amber heard's
testimony because
and i did i did write like i listened to
the
the clip and i put down things that
stood out to me
that the dr curry said
of like
overly dramatic presentation it's like
the way she recounts stories sound like
a like a
someone put it to me like a romance
novel
yeah
lots of embellishments yeah
impressionistic speech
very flowery
feels like it often lacks any substance
a big part is quick shift between
emotions
like she'll do the face that like really
like the crying face like trying to cry
and then and then she could just switch
out of it
like it's it's bizarre
it's it is bizarre it's just like this
like
like
it's not even like a recovery you know
of it it's it's like a whoa like
it's like someone yelled cut
yeah
and then i guess someone's like
or something you know yeah yeah so then
are we to believe that those are
decisions or are those just how she
express i don't know it's like i've met
people who who in just regular life who
kind of meet that criteria the pain
in
the audio tapes not when they're like i
didn't hit you johnny but like the p
when she is
divulging pain
again you know it's like look i don't
think she's a talented of an actress
and it's when she's
you know it's like it is the thing of
all these we're trying to factor in like
all the of the possible different
circumstances if we are to
obviously i
i pretty much have an opinion on her and
uh
and i i i go okay let me assume now that
she's telling the truth of why i might
have a hard time believing her if she is
telling the truth yeah
um
i do want to get into that bottle story
i i do i do i do want to because
that's like that's the one i'm i am the
most like trepidicious to touch
uh at the same time there are things
i've heard on both sides and i'm like
well
let me talk about that but what was i
just talking about i keep forgetting my
my train of thought we're talking about
her
personality traits and the way she
portrays emotions and things like that
and her investigating things in the
table oh yeah oh yeah the tape she
sounds sincere
but that's a different environment
than what she's had to do with
pretty much two weeks of being told all
these like
she must go online and see how people
respond she fired her pr team oh yeah
this trial no she has to know she knows
i mean she's because she's been living
with this longer than the truck it's
constantly reported on how many
signatures are on that remove amber
heard from aquaman 2
yeah
petition which has been up since before
this trial well before yeah yeah so like
that's why it's it's like she
like the the best case i can give her is
if she is telling the truth she's having
a hard time
because she feels she has to put up
a certain type of one-woman show
in order to try to sell them like keep
looking directly at the jury
like really you know cheat your body
with them yeah yeah tell them and
it does seem like over the top but but i
can't
even as someone who doubts the the
validity of some of a lot of what she
talks about
it i can't
say i'm like i've met people who are
really dramatic
and that to me contributes to this she's
from she's an actress in l.a
crying out loud
that's the first thought i had the first
thought i had
was i feel like i'm watching an actor do
a monologue and acting class and
okay it was like it felt like acting
class time yeah yeah
i don't know see that's the thing is i
can see it
and
and i i don't have a good uh like
conclusion based on it i'm like i can
see what you're talking about and there
are elements of the way that she you
know it's like you watch johnny depp on
the stand and he's very much just like
super chill and just answering questions
occasionally laughing whereas yeah she
is
there to prove a point which to be fair
i mean she is there to prove a point uh
yeah it really makes me wonder because
if it is just that her personality is
that way
uh and
you know she's up here giving a
testimony then of course that's going to
be consistent with how her personality
is and if that's all true then
she must be sharing her
her side of the she must believe what
she's saying i guess is
what i imagine if again we can trust
that account of her
psychology because then you hear these
tapes and you can hear yeah some
instances of like yeah it sounds like
she's in pretty much peril in this
recording
or whatever um
yeah again
it's one of those things where i feel
like in certain ways they're probably
both telling what they think is true and
i i can't
i don't know it feels to me like there
are two teams the johnny depp's team is
people who love johnny depp and i feel
like amber heard's team is mostly people
who care about
assault victims
not people who really care that much
about amber heard and so that's
what makes me i think there's i think
giant has a lot in his camp
more i like that i think there's a giant
just the jdep super fans and i and i
also think there are people who
uh who do suffer domestic violence and
believe him they're
even i believed amber heard at first
you know yeah and i don't know i mean i
don't
not believe
a hundred percent of the things she said
just because again looking at all this
evidence and looking at the situation
clearly there is abuse between two
people happening and i think what they
are trying to do is figure out who the
primary abuser was
and uh that's that's just a nasty
nasty task uh
figuring out if johnny depp defended
himself or attacked her
and to if if i think i don't think
there's a way to truly know no you can't
no you can't no you can't it's it's it's
hard it's like you choose you choose to
you have to choose to
you choose what you believe yeah that's
why i always say this is what i believe
you know like i i'm choosing what i
believe here yeah
because not one of them goes
i mean depending on the subject but like
yeah i haven't heard johnny depp in a
private conversation ever say like i hit
you
because i was defending myself although
there was that thing with like the toes
and like having to get away so
accidentally hurt her yeah yeah
thing yeah yeah and the door on her feet
yeah so there's that and then
the biggest discrediter of amber heard
for me is that is the recording
are those recordings where she's
basically saying like yeah i start these
fights for this reason and i didn't hit
you i hit you this way and your response
is invalid because of this well then you
hear all that and you hear her testify
and then the test and the testimony
seems a little bizarre yeah then you go
i don't know if i could believe you yeah
that's the most telltale and the
stickiest detail that like that's the
thing that keeps me coming back to at
least her side of this and going
something doesn't feel quite on the
level here and i can't really tell well
the bottle incident i mean look it up i
don't want to like fully recount it
um it it does
what a lot of i've heard some people say
like
logically this is what i mean they don't
say the words logically but that's what
everyone's implying is logically if
johnny depp
did do that bottle incident
wouldn't she want to go to the hospital
and get that checked out she could have
suffered injuries from
that there could be an infection there's
a lot of things
yeah logically
at the same time that a big problem is
many people especially like in you know
marital situations
even non-marital
they don't go to the hospital they don't
get checked out uh
they don't report it like there's a
there's it's very very common so i
so i'm like yeah of course logically you
should but i'm not gonna be here being
like here's why i don't believe
that didn't happen it it'd be because of
the logic of not getting that checked
out
logic is always a bad place to turn and
assault cases i think
we've had too many accounts now not to
realize that like yeah you don't
necessarily behave logically when these
things happen and especially something
is intimate and and yes i don't know
like
you got to feel embarrassed and violated
in in a myriad of ways after a situation
like that that probably wouldn't make a
lot of people actually want to go seek
out like let me go find people in public
and deal with this you know yeah i mean
even when like johnny depp got his
finger cut off
like he lied and said that he did it in
i mean according to his testimony key
member's name out of it that yeah you
know it's and so it's like if amber
heard it's going there and like here's
what happened you know there's that fear
there's a lot of reasons i could justify
as to why she didn't go too
well and that did happen
yeah and i mean
i feel like if there's also a position
to be like okay i got a piece of my
finger sliced off but we're gonna
protect her still i feel like that's
also indicative of a situation in which
those kinds of things might
be a little more common than you like if
that was a first time offense and that
was the crossing of a line i don't know
if that would be the response it could
be but it it feels to me more indicative
of a toxic scenario where things like
this actually do kind of happen and
maybe this was an extreme case but
you know
things like this do happen with us
yeah no they
it's just such a heavy accusation yes
and regardless and if that is not the
truth
in a lot of ways that doesn't matter for
a lot of people because a lot of people
already believe it
you know if it's not true i mean if it's
not like it's that is among the most
vile things you can do is fabricate a
scenario like that
she just i keep going back to
how she testifies
i keep going back to that that's part of
it like because the thing is we've seen
like countless people testify this for
yeah and she's a very specific type of
person when she's testifying and a lot
of it seems to be looking at the jury
for approval on a lot of her behaviors
there's this one moment
that people are saying she posed for a
photo like with the tissue
and usually when i hear that i'm like
that sounds like a reach
then when i watch it i'm like
god damn it really does seem as i am
likely to believe that she is you you
see her like
put the tissue on look up
hold still click and then go you hear
the click of the camera yeah and then go
away
and then i'm like and sure enough that's
the photo yes of course yeah i mean if
she especially if she replaced her pr
team i mean you know she's aware of
things like that and and part of me the
sympathetic side of me goes well that's
smart because you know that that's one
of the assets that you especially need
to play into but at the same time it is
a contrivance you know it is a bit
disingenuous if that is in fact the case
yeah uh rings like i don't i don't know
where to land on that it doesn't ring at
least like a genuine like i'm just
wiping a tear
like that bottle story's so
horrific
and for someone to say like where's the
evidence i'm like
i i i would say
get out of here with that it's really
hard to
if that's a private moment
it's really hard to just be like
well why don't you take photos
like you can't just say that to someone
you know you you can't when you're nice
position
you take photos
and the thing is that subject that story
in particular it's like
again if that is the truth
then
bravery for sharing that
and doing this
if that is not the truth it is such an
evil manipulative thing
to do to people who are watching this
she knows people are watching this
terrible to do to join dad you know
and pin
and terrible new giant debt but there
are there are like i said there are
individuals who have had instances like
that and worse and consistently
in domestic partnerships
that would then
that that makes them
immediately like you would just believe
that person
like there are people who would just
instantly believe that there are people
that who have been in those situations
who don't believe her though
for that case and not just because
they're johnny depp superfans because
they'll be like well here's a lot of
things of why this doesn't sound real
and it's and a lot of it comes down to
the way
she paints it yeah yeah i mean you got
to help yourself just as much as any of
the other witnesses have you know on
your side have to help you it's like she
kind of talks like the issue i have and
i know it sounds like i'm making a joke
the issue i had when i was trying to
read tarantino's once upon a time in
hollywood book okay that would
flip between
telling
like okay sometimes this book sounds
like
a novel most of the time he's writing
the the the non-dialogue scenes like
action lines in a script yeah you know
yeah yeah yeah
like it it doesn't seem like she's
really
i don't really like reliving a memory
yeah it it sounds
made it sound it's like oh
sometimes it reads to me that you
remember breaking bad
when walter white made that fake
confession
yes about hank
in the last season yeah sometimes it
reads like that but a worse performance
than that
you know
um
so yeah it's so hard to tell it's so
hard to tell because yeah i can't
sometimes things just come out awkward
and stiff
or
some people aren't very good at acting
yeah
obviously we're trying to be a little
bit
fairer here
i think compared to 99 of the discourse
we've entertained both sides pretty well
because i don't know ultimately justice
for somebody just just as
uh
like so hard here let me i'll i'll end
it with this
the trial is not done there's more to
come there's counter
i'm blanking on so many words
for
a discussion video like counter
depositions no no no no
cross-examination yeah yeah it's
cross-examination uh there's
cross-examination
there's there's there's more to come out
you know
and this was the first time i've ever
really listened like
let's listen to amber heard talk
and i went in with an open mind
and as much as i
i'd like i just remember hearing her cry
and be like
let me pull up my phone and look at this
yeah yeah yeah i don't know man
yeah it's tough it's tough there are
certain things that you should just
never do like there's a certain
percentage of this where i'm just like
it's just two people who are really
abusive towards each other although
there are certain allegations where i'm
just like that's something no person
should ever do and
be allowed to just maintain their happy
life from you know if if some of these
you know nastier allegations are true so
i mean for me personally i don't feel
like i'll ever know the answer and i'm
probably gonna remember this whenever i
think of either of them from now on
um but yeah
it's gonna keep unfolding and then
there's gonna be another trial in uh the
fall so we'll have this to relive again
[Laughter]
get ready for christmas
with amber heard and johnny depp yeah
yeah i don't know i like i i can't
discredit her entirely because i think
there's a zealousness that people have
in doing so and i think it's a bit
dangerous for the overall discourse
for that to happen but i think there are
a lot of legitimate there's a lot of
legitimate skepticism i think about how
she's approaching this and leading into
this trial and even before these trials
were things she didn't have always the
best reputation on a personal level
um not to say that your ex-wife and
stuff yeah and uh you know that is what
it is the past as we said for johnny
depp the past is the past you know now
is what we're talking about but at the
same time you know
i don't want to fully
i can't but she had good conscience she
had just she was in the transition
process of leaving that relationship and
then went right into this one yeah no
it's never that is rarely a recipe for a
good relationship so i'm saying if she
was that person in that relationship
then i'm like i don't think she like
changed
yeah yeah not
not just getting into this relationship
now i'm a whole new person yeah totally
and i mean you can see too things where
people who start out really all about
each other as they describe like oh man
it's obsession yeah and and like you
said
passion can often be driven by a certain
kind of of dysfunction and a certain
kind of pain and i feel like more than
anything else we've learned here it's
just that these two people harmonized
pain and trauma
and got a lot more of it in the process
even when she's testifying and maybe
this is just a smart choice on johnny
depp's end he does not watch her
he does not look up at her
that was the thing is i was watching for
hours to to be that committed to like
hurting your neck and back because you
just refused to look up at your abuser
yeah that
it's interesting to see again it's it's
where she just like looks at him coldly
stuff like this like weird mannequin
look that she's watching yeah you watch
it during all of his testimonies and for
the most part she's very still and then
occasionally we'll get that verge of
tears face
and then kind of oscillate before the
trial seems like she's been trying to
cry and just can't quite get there
yeah
i can't i can't tell if it's somebody
who's too exhausted to cry or somebody
who's really trying to cry when you're
making that face for hours and hours on
end i'm talking about when she's
testifying you'd think a real tear would
a couple couple streams might come out a
little bit
you would imagine after a couple of
weeks at this
yeah the emotional toll has to win yeah
that would have to be a little bit of
like i'm finally talking you know
but then again i mean the other thing
that it might just be so bottled up and
repressed they've already tested she's
already had to testify this stuff once
and and live for months with just this
whole situation i'm sure absorbing her
life so again
the problem for me is i can never get to
a thing where i'm like a hundred percent
now
you know
i understand
at this current moment i have a really
hard time believing her i do
like just and i i'm mainly going off of
yeah i already had an opinion
but then watching and nor am i saying
johnny depp's a [ __ ] saint you know
but so he yeah like the image that he's
painted
of her
sounds like a weird choice to say a
choice of words to say
but it's
but it
sounds like a fair portrayal of
what he believes to be his abuser
she is describing
something else entirely
the appearance definitely does feel that
way so that's what just makes me even
more doubtful like you're you're trying
too hard
but i don't know maybe like for all i
know she might whip something out next
week
and i'm like holy [ __ ] i take back
everything you know yeah it's not over
until it's over and it's probably not
over then either you know they they have
to they this is this is a sales pitch to
the jury it is 100 you you can't and and
and one of the biggest things is you got
to plant the seed
what you got to do in a court trial
is you plant the seed
to
so that way when the people start coming
up defending the individual you're
doubting it
but you have to really bring it home in
the end yeah you know yeah yeah you've
got to put stamp on it it's like there's
more audio there's more [ __ ] there's so
much more [ __ ] yeah they could that
could they could have just like let me
just dump all this in the beginning but
they didn't do that
you gotta spread it out you know you
gotta build the narrator you gotta build
to the finale mm-hmm you know and that's
the impression you're gonna be left with
yes you gotta convince 10 people of your
side yeah
how many people are in a jury
you know
a baker's dozen
yeah i mean what it where i am right now
is basically that and like clearly there
was abuse between two people and what
i'm dubious about or what i'm curious as
to the legitimacy of is the most extreme
claims
of like direct abuse that i don't think
could have come out of some kind of
blackout scenario
and unprovoked you know like those truly
dastardly allegations are the ones i'm
most curious about because i think
again i think this well establishes that
they abused each other
through their relationship for whatever
understandable reason or not you know i
feel like that is true so i i don't
really fall on the side of like no just
johnny
[ __ ] it yeah you know like like it is a
very human like to i it gets people very
charged for very legitimate reasons and
if i remove myself from the emotion and
and you know the experiences of people i
know it is a fascinating
just experiment to peer in on in terms
of you know
psych psychology and and sociology well
it's not like it's because the reason
why it's so one-sided i mean a i'm
always
the thing i'm constantly bitching about
is how there seems to be a lack of gray
with any subject in this world
gotta choose one and once you've chosen
you can never unchoose that yeah yeah
you can never act on new information you
will be judged from your previous belief
yeah you know yeah
like i i it's like
you know you like this seems to be such
a hypocrisy with the idea of growth and
change
um
like you should and then when you do no
yeah
you're in hell
so you can never make the right decision
yeah so it's it's a pain in the it's a
pain in the ass
um
so uh
well that's my god it's happening again
there was there was a point
there's something about oh where are we
just saying yeah john
this one gets cut out during all the
evidence
uh
just the shadow of a doubt stuff the
sort of like the biggest
the biggest most damning allegations
uh
something about them
well yeah just to me
the truth of the matter right now is
that at very least it seems evident they
both were abusive
toward each other for various reasons
and i just don't know if the most vile
and the most
sort of clearly
victim and aggressor
ones are the truth
see i can believe a scenario
this is where
you piss off the world i i can believe a
scenario of johnny depp being so
inebriated
that he doesn't remember doing it
i absolutely believe that's possible
i've seen it happen in life he's a bit
of a rock and roll star you know yeah
even though in his testimony
he is saying like he doesn't ever get to
that point
where he doesn't you know and like those
photos were
those photos i don't think are
condemning damning evidence i i don't
believe they are condemning him like
he's passed out do you see the way that
ice cream hit his leg he's got a crazy
lifestyle he's it works weird hours you
know yeah i've fallen asleep in this
room yeah this very room i've fallen
asleep in just like at a computer and
i'm like oh god i just dozed off all
editing yeah
100 you know and you're a drunk and an
addict
for doing so yeah um yeah but i i i i
don't think uh
i i really don't believe though that
he's
i could be wrong
he doesn't believe like a malicious guy
he doesn't seem like the kind of guy who
would get emotional to the point he
would strike you
right it doesn't seem as though the only
way i could believe he would like might
have hit
it
was if he was that inebriated and it
wasn't a fight
either that or or in a situation where
there were already hands being thrown or
something yeah or something yeah where
he was already been provoked you know
like i don't know like it's weird and
and this is a we we brought you to end
this but yeah that's that's what i mean
it's a never-ending talk
well yeah and why there's channels who
have committed their lives
because there's so much to the human
nuance and the weird gray areas and and
two the fact that we're zooming in and
focusing in on little details way more
than you do under normal circumstances
and those can cause those details to
unfold or to suggest things that you
might not have seen and also too there's
the bias of what are you looking for
because you might just find what you're
looking for rather than what is actually
happening
you know like there's there's so much to
it and it's really fascinating because
while it's created this very polar
division it's like
to me a very unpolarized situation when
you really dig deep into it and yeah i
feel like
yeah like something could have happened
where if he was blacked out
sure which is its own thing that should
have consequences that should be dealt
with it's not saying it did that's not
we're not here saying he did do that i'm
saying like that's the scenario i could
believe
that's what they see if they prove that
you know that's what seemed most likely
yeah i mean it seems like it would have
had to have happened at some point
but i don't uh
i don't know i don't rely on this yeah
this is why i don't do we don't do like
daily videos we don't want to make the
channel about this
no but it's something that
you know
is a part of entertainment media now is
this is why
you know that thing that drew barry when
you see that thing when did you very
much had a friggin apologize for talking
with anthony anderson about the trial oh
no she was talking she was pretty much
the the language and the description of
her experience
was talking about it in a way that's
like entertainment
oh
and which rub people
the wrong way yeah because it shouldn't
be it's become that it's a circus but it
shouldn't be entertainment
it shouldn't be
but i think too for
millions of people it certainly is this
is yeah for millions of people this is
the best tmz episode you could
you could go on tick tock and you'll see
a ton of people just being like getting
my popcorn ready you know like that
michael jackson gift has to be
everywhere it's like this is a this is a
this is a source of this has become a
main source of entertainment
and like like i said i could i could i i
could be here every day without john
because i have like
i keep up to date with this and i really
listen i don't just listen to clips you
know like i'm really paying attention oh
yeah whenever whenever i go to examine
the trial i'm like where's that seven
hour live stream yeah let me put this on
five speed yeah
you can see my red mark on where i'm at
you know i'm catching up too like
because we share the same account so
yeah
so you're watching on law and crime are
you on crime network okay maybe i'll
switch to them i've been on nbc
maybe their coverage is what pops up for
me yeah that's what i use
um yeah like it's this is it's a really
fascinating thing and people are eating
it up like an like a form of
entertainment and even
people got to be honest about that
even before
you know people who are taking this
serious like it's really hard for me to
come on here and just make jokes about
this well and like just do like funny
meme reactions and [ __ ] like that
because i think to be able to do that
you have to have a conclusion you have
to feel like you know
or a lot of people feel like they know
or have a distance from it yeah you know
like these people don't really matter to
me haha like i want to make
jokes about ezra
miller
if i was seeing videos of him throwing a
chair at a woman and damaging her face
yeah you know and so now it's making me
i mean i don't think i made jokes in
that video
but
i'm not making light of that scenario no
no
um
that's the i don't know i'm trying to
use a different example
didn't make jokes about will smith that
was stupid though that's not the same
that's
it's the difference this is a different
thing yeah it's not the same thing yeah
yeah
yeah you know
there's there's a ladder
yeah and the slapping is is rung one
it's not not the biblical times if every
sin is equal
yeah yeah yeah absolutely
it must be judged um
but i mean it's it's fascinating and
engrossing but it more just makes me sad
than than like oh fun you know
it's not enough
i don't think this is
am i amused and entertained by it of
course i am i think a lot of us are oh
yeah but at the same time i wouldn't
i wouldn't necessarily use the words
at times charles [ __ ] boring as [ __ ]
it's like a drama that happens to be
funny on occasion
because life is occasionally funny it's
like yeah johnny depp will make a remark
that's kind of a zinger and it's funny
but yeah at the same time the situation
at hand is very it's if you get invested
you know
it's like
you know it's engrossing you know you
people who watch like true crime
documentaries who want to be like this
is not entertaining
yeah i don't like that okay let's look
over your netflix account and see if you
like
murders
murders are less messed up than
personal relationships
all right like
which are arguably might be true and
then the one thing we didn't touch on is
the subject too of like men who suffer
domestic violence yeah which is which is
a thing that is like there are men who
laugh at this subject
like she hit you so what don't be a
[ __ ] you know
i mean and johnny depp coming from the
family of with an abusive a mother who
apparently abused his father and is
triggering him yeah like like it's
common it's much more of an accepted
standard for a woman to slap a guy
like he was out of line he messed up he
cheated or something like whatever it is
uh you know he was being stupid that's
that's the realm i don't
i would be curious to hear people who
know a lot more than me unpack that one
because part of me is like well if we do
live in this weird in in this equal
world
you know it's like you shouldn't nobody
should hit anybody
and you know i i still kind of have that
belief from
how i you know just the kind of default
settings of growing up of like yeah
man doesn't hit woman it's just not
something you do as bad as immediate
line cross but then i think of these
situations where it's just like
two people fighting each other
yeah and like it's it's that that's why
i guess it comes down to the primary
aggressor question because after a
certain point part of me
if you isolate the worst allegations and
certain other things it is just sort of
like this is just two toxic people
fighting each other and so if hands were
thrown on both sides it seems like it
it cancels out not that it cancels the
actions taken and the harm done by those
but it cancels out like the innocence
factor to me where it's just like
you're kind of both on that level
together
and there's yeah that view of like well
it's immediately [ __ ] up if it's a man
hitting a woman which again i i still
have that in my dna but at the same time
it makes me curious about like well if
you just have two people who are
fighting
back and forth
you know and you don't know yet who the
primary aggressor is like what what is
that situation exactly like if you know
if a woman is laying into a guy and
hitting him a bunch you know and he hits
back what are the rules of that like i'm
actually curious to hear some good
theory and thought on that because i
haven't really
had to think much about that
you know
i mean
i feel like my train of thought is like
if she's punching him a bunch or
something you gotta like just push her
away or or you block or push her away
whatever
you know like use your foot to like kick
her away yeah but if you're but if
you're talking about a situation in
which a man like clock them in the face
like like get to get away from me yeah
you know if you are a man and i guess to
clarify if you are a man in an abusive
situation for example and you are being
physically harmed in either repeatedly
or in a specific incident what are the
rules of that like what are you you know
what is messed up
to you know what what kind of
retaliation or defensive measure is
messed up and i think there's a pretty
clear line you can find of when defense
transfers when you go too far
you know and then it's like whoa slow
down you know like now you're you're
flying off the handle but you know in an
abusive situation where the male is the
victim yeah what what are the full
ethics
of
that
missile strike is too far yes yes yes
you don't launch a missile on your
partner
but yeah you know because right there
you've lost a fight because there's that
immediate thing of like if a man hits a
woman that's kind of an immediate like a
violent assault like there's something
very ugly that naturally comes to that
that i don't you know take any
issue with the response thereof but yeah
if it's you know if if that type of
abuse is happening
and it's physical abuse towards a man
what are the rules
you know
when are when are you
not uh [ __ ] up in yeah
defending physically i guess
we'll keep a lookout for our dr strange
spoiler talk
after this delightful
brief sojourn into the real world a lot
of our audience is listening to this
trial
a lot of everybody's listening to this
trial see what else our audience is
listening to
oh
hey they're watching this obscure
documentary
yeah let's cover that now yeah
let's watch some let's do it all
horrific true crime series
react to the dirty details
this video is finally done or audio
depending on what we decide
we did it see you guys
aquaman two
you